so uh
earlier today i got to do this
in case you missed my previous videos on
the subject i wrote a book and it's out
today it's called firmament and it's an
introduction to and history of
atmospheric science it's not a textbook
it's not a technical book this is
basically the book that i wish i could
have read when i was in school or
starting university that would have
gotten me interested in atmospheric
science if you're wondering if it's any
good then obviously i would say it is
but we've had some fantastic early
reviews both the sunday times and the
financial times have given it really
positive reviews so yeah i think it's
good you can get it in physical copies
or as an ebook or as an audio book which
i narrated myself which was an
interesting experience this is obviously
location specific it's available in
physical form in most places but in
north america the physical copies are
out in september i think the digital
copies may be available now
smells like an e-book do you want to
hear it
if you want to know if it feels weird
holding a book with your name on it that
you wrote
uh
yeah as a matter of fact i actually
filmed my unboxing of the first load of
books the publisher sent me a load a
couple of weeks ago to send out to
friends and family and people who helped
me with the project and um
yeah here you go my heart is
about to burst out of my chest oh my god
oh my god
i just saw a little glimpse
holding tens of thousands of words that
i wrote in my hand i have no words i
don't i don't know what to say
oh god there's a picture of me i don't
know why that's a surprise
it's like that joking hot fuzz oh my god
oh my god i wish i had something clever
to say but i really don't i'm just
ironically for a man who has written
tens of thousands of them
lost for words
i think since then i've
accepted this in the abstract like i
i know that i've written a book i know
that it is this book and i know that's
my name and all of these words are words
that i wrote
i get that in abstract i don't think
it's quite sunk in yet i don't know if
it ever really sinks in um but
i
it's a thing i i actually
achieved a childhood dream i've always
wanted to be an author
and
here i am some of my favorite places in
the world when i was a kid were
libraries and bookshops and partly
that's because they just had this calm
atmosphere but also because
they had these they had these little
mini universes that you could lose
yourself in and
the authors were almost like kind of
mythic figures there were these people
who created universes that invited you
to open them up and dive in and
it was it was like they were magicians
or gods and
right now in
book shops and i don't know about
libraries yet but bookshops around the
country
and around the world
i'm on the shelf now it turns out that
some bookshops have actually got their
copies of the book i've been putting
them out on the shelves early ahead of
the release date so i have cycled into
bath and i'm going to be looking in yes
believe it or not that is a bookshop i'm
going to be looking in and seeing if i
can find and maybe do some stealth
signing of
my book
oh my god there it is
here we are
oh my god this is wild
this is really really wild
something my editor said to me was that
it's terrifying being in a bookshop
because
there are so many books how on earth are
you supposed to sell yours
frankly i am
over the moon
i'm just in the building
this is
this is amazing
i wanted to make this quick video to
commemorate the occasion but also to say
thank you because
i wouldn't have had the opportunity to
write a book if it hadn't been for this
community of people on youtube but also
people on my discord and on twitch and
[Music]
you know this in that sense is as much
your book as it is mine this is an
opportunity that i was afforded because
of you lovely people choosing to watch
the content that i make and so from the
bottom of my heart i want to say if
you've watched one video of mine or a
hundred
thank you actually mentioning twitch if
you're watching this video on the day
that it came out then i'm going to be
doing a live stream on my twitch channel
dr simon clark where i'm going to be
answering people's questions about the
book and just kind of generally
celebrating with the community so i'll
leave a link to my twitch down in the
description it's going to be at 4pm gmt
but if you're watching this after the
fact then still go to the twitch channel
and follow and drop me your twitch prime
subscription what i wish i had some
complicated message to tie this video
together really elegantly but
i just wanted to say thank you i wanted
to say thank you for giving me the
opportunity to write this book and thank
you for allowing me to
fulfill a childhood dream and thank you
for giving me the opportunity to
hopefully have made something that's
got value and is actually going to add
something to the world and get people
interested in and better informed about
the atmosphere it's something that i
really care deeply about and
i wouldn't be able to do it if it wasn't
for you so
thank you in addition to being
appreciative of everyone who watches
this channel i do have a couple of extra
thank yous to say to do with the book
over the course of the project i had two
editors at hodder and stoughton ian wong
and hugh armstrong ian and hugh you made
this book what it is and you showed me
that every good book needs a very good
editor thanks also to my agent chris
welbelov all the people who are listed
in the acknowledgements as giving notes
on previous versions again this book
would not be what it is without your
help and of course the biggest thank you
of all to pixel girl who has supported
me like a rock throughout this process
she's been there through highs and lows
and has just kept my motivation up
she's just the best and this book
wouldn't have been possible without her
if you'd like to read or listen to the
book then there'll be links down there
in the description don't forget i'm
doing that twitch stream this afternoon
if you're watching this on the 27th or
just come and swing by my twitch after
the fact because i really like streaming
and that just leads me to say thank you
for watching i have no idea how to end
this video by the way like i it's been
so long since i've done a video without
a script that i'm i'm just going to pop
the end screen things up and say thank
you again for watching and thank you for
giving me this opportunity
i wrote a book